a ship inspection team is underway in
the Gulf of Guinea this boarding team
from benin in west africa spot a cargo
ship it's Russian crew and sits there
transporting only vegetables but the
anti-piracy team are suspicious they
search the crew and their ship such
situations are common in West Africa's
waters but in this case the Russian crew
members are actually soldiers the
freighter really a warship everyone here
is taking part in oban game Express a
large at sea exercise held off the coast
of Nigeria at least 20 nations are
involved including Germany let's get
rookies mouths it's really about
training going through the procedures
and about learning from each other
that's our focus here we've been able to
study the varying practices of different
countries so even though we have a
comparatively large Navy it's definitely
been a successful exercise for us I'm
grateful for that Germany sent 670
soldiers and four ships to take part in
the drill close to Nigeria's capital
lagos countries started running the Obon
game Express exercise back in 2010 it's
always been large but for years on
participation is greater than ever be
its pain or Cameroon many nations need
secure trade routes of West Africa
piracy there is soaring last year more
than twice as many ships were attacked
there than off the east coast of the
continent
nearby countries are increasing their
efforts to tackle privacy gov of uni
correctly is witnessing a lot of fair
you know problem particularly of piracy
issue of some other forms of the
legalities within the waters and of
course this exercise is one of those you
know exercises you know aimed at you
know stemming the tide you know bringing
it down you know to the BRS minimum so I
believe that the SSR has you know played
a lot of role in doing that trainers use
harsh methods during the exercise but
everyone here knows that violence would
be part of any real-life attack